Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And today we're talking about,
well we're trying to think about what goes on in the mind of a bad person.
What makes a bad person so bad that he's different from the rest of us?
And we didn't really come to any kind of agreement with the hopper thing. Yeah,
I don't think we quite the scope, but you know,
we ended up walking this question around to different people want to talk about
bad people in Shakespeare. And oddly enough we came,
got a really interesting take on the true nature of badness from this Guy James
Shapiro,
professor of English at Columbia University and he said to start,
you want to know about bad? I'll give you bad. In Titus Andronicus.
There's a character by the name of Aaron, the Moore,
and there's a moment in the play where Aaron gets up on stage,
looks at the audience and says,
let me just tell you the kinds of things I've been up to recently
set deadly. And the t between two friends make poor man's cattle,
break their necks, set fire on bonds,
and he stacks in the night and bit the onus quench sumps quench them with it.
Tears off.
Have I digged up dead men from their graves and sit them upright of their dear
friends door? Oh,
even even when their sorrows almost where for God and on their skins is on the
bark of trees have wind my life with my knife carved in Roman letters.
Let not your sorrows die though I am dead.
So he's bad. Yeah. But see, here's the interesting thing. According to James,
he is not the bad s no in Shakespeare or in life because ultimately the play
offers up a reason for his nastiness. The reason why
tell telling all this stuff is because he has cut a deal.
They will spare his son if he fesses up and and tells them what they need to
know. So there's a way in which is a touch of spark of humanity,
just a little glimmer.
And he says that's what people wanted.
They wanted someone who was really thrillingly bad,
but in the end was redeemed a bit. Yeah.
This wasn't just a theater thing. Oh.
Cause if you couldn't afford a ticket for a play,
you'd seen all the plays in the 1500
I always go to a public hanging and you'd go for much of the same reasons.
And those days, if you're a convicted male felon, you are, you know, strung up,
but you're not allowed to hang until you die.
You're cut down before then warning, this next part's a little graphic.
Then the executioner castrates you cuts you open and takes out your internal
organs and then separates your head, which was put on a post.
But even with all that Gore and horribleness,
there was often a moment that people waited for.
And in a way we wait for it still. Even now,
we want what Elizabeth and Scott at the scaffold,
which was a confession before the guy is cut to shreds.
He's allowed to confess. You know, I, I hardly, you know,
regret the fact that I kill the young maiden or defame the king, whatever it is.
The expectation is somebody is made to make his peace with his maker before he
dies. That's
what you do and that's what Shakespeare did and all his plays.
He would give all his batteries at least one moment where they could be
understood except this one time
[inaudible] you [inaudible]
yeah, he is a soldier.
He works for a general general general's name is a fellow there supposedly
chums, but general a fellow has no idea that he algo
heats.
So he plans to destroy a fellow and then we don't exactly know why.
There are hints of reasons like maybe he thinks a fellow sleeping with his wife,
we're not sure.
But the weird thing is that he decides not just to take down the fellow,
but everybody
Easters up hatred between friends, between lovers,
he even schemes against his own wife.
This is just somebody who's performing brain surgery without anesthesia on other
people.
He's a master plotter and as for why maybe a fellow was sleeping with Amelia,
but as the play goes on, you begin to think that maybe that's just another lie.
Eventually Iago convinces Othello that his wife has been disloyal,
which she hasn't. And then Othello goes and kills his own wife,
smothering her with a pillow.
This is just that tsunami of evil or passes through the place.
Did you start moving your head?
The very end of the play, when everyone finds out what he all goes done,
fellow asks him why? Why did you do this?
Any Jago he refuses what
we fully expect and what everybody on stage at that moment fully expects from
him. You know? What does he say?
I'm demand mean nothing. What you know,
you know
from this time forth, I never will speak word.
I'm not saying a word. I'm not going to give you what you want.
I'm not going to give you,
I'm not going to help restore the sense that there is a moral order to the world
and a moral norm.
[inaudible]. What you know, you know,
if this is the singular moment in Shakespeare where he gives you an
understandably evil man, no motives, no reason.
Well, any idea what the hell he was intending?
What you know you
meaning, I mean w w any idea what he was in his mind?
Was he trying to make a commentary?
It's and who was he grappling with something? Do we know? You know? Dammit.
Okay.
The goody Argos make you want to shower the minute you leave the theater because
you are sullied by them.
Thank you to James Shapiro whose most recent book is called contested will,
you know what? Yeah, you there? Yeah.
Well you know what I'm left thinking though is like if you could somehow,
I mean that was make belief,
but if you could somehow get a real Jago in the room and subject that person to
questioning and really get them to sort of fess up as to why they did it,
would that make a difference?
We should say that this next section of the program has some references which
are extremely graphic and not to everybody's taste. So we have kids in the,
in the room and maybe this is a time to tell them to go brush their teeth or
something. Yeah, yeah. It comes to us from our reporter.
Parents matter. Yes. Jeff Johnson. Nice to meet you. All right, so who is,
who is this guy? We're here.
This is Jeff Jensen and he's a reporter in La and he wrote this graphic novel
that I read about one of the most prolific serial killers in u s history,
Gary Leon Ridgeway,
the green river killer.
The first victims of the green river killer were found in the summer of 1982 and
the green river murders terrorized Seattle in the 1980s in Seattle today,
a man called the green river killer.
Ridgeway murdered at least 49 women called green river killer. Right?
It's suspected that it could be upwards of 75 making him the most prolific
serial killer in American history. All the victims were prostitutes.
He buried them or left their bodies in these little clumps in the woods.
The kind of seemed to a place the bodies as if they were mannequins.
And in January of 1984,
the green river task force was formed and my father was recruited to the task
force. So Jeff wrote this book because his father,
Tom Jensen was one of the lead detectives tracking Gary Ridgway.
He ultimately spent 17 years searching for this man. In December of 2001,
my father and his colleagues make the arrest DNA testing matched him to the
crime they arrest Gary Lee
Leon Ridgeway. And on June 13th, 2003,
Gary was secretly taken out of his jail cell and brought to a sort of very
nondescript concrete ugly office building.
And um, over the next six months,
from June to early December,
it was Tom's job to get Gary to open up and give up the few details that they
really needed to link him certifiably to all these crimes.
Today's date is June 17th, 2003.
The time now is the eight 36 hours.
So every day they would bring them into this conference room.
This is a continuation of an interview with Gary Neon.
Ridgeway and interrogate him.
What did you remember since we last talked to you?
I've got those all interned at, at the time mostly, um,
some that, uh, I remember picking her up at.
Um,
it immediately became apparent that there was going to be different
faculties as far as I know. I don't know if I did or not.
Nine things. He would obscure.
He would dance around things you didn't really want a cop to everything that he
did. I gotta tell you a, I mean, not
totally comfortable that you're providing all the answers
formation, especially when it came to one particular fact.
What my father and his colleagues know is that something was done to these body
and many of them after they were murdered. Does he, is he saying,
I think he's saying, Yup.
Necrophilia Gary is dancing around this topic.
Gary had denied this to his own lawyers and that we're not going to be,
so my father and the other interviewer in that room, that morning,
detective John Mattson, they start using a line of,
uh, attack, uh, of interviewing him. That was very,
it's okay. It's okay if you did. Stunningly,
shockingly empathetic. Nothing to be ashamed.
Thousands of people it you, I'm not the first one. You know,
you're not the first person that's ever done this. Not going to be the last one.
You won't be the last as one of the things that we,
we need to know the father father's trying to like reach out to him. Okay.
I know it was more than heritage. It's okay to admit this.
You need to admit this. Okay. It's all right. We've got to note that.
That's one of the things we have to know and that's why it's okay to let him and
he does a yes, I did lie about that
potentially was a wood back one time before then. You call me.
Some of them that I,
like I said, I've got to give it out. I can't keep [inaudible] moments
like this was a major breakthrough,
so he ends up in mitigants in graphic detail and it gets even more disturbing
for my father as the conversation suddenly pivots to another victim
other than one
that was real close to me by the name of Carol Christian Centered Christiansen.
I dated her several times, three times, two times.
He brings her up as an example of a,
of a woman that he actually had strong feelings for
like just like this girl, like glade liked her, she was skinny,
she was good to me
and as it happens my father has very vivid memories of investigating the Carol
Christianson murder. Speaking with Carol's mom,
Carol's little daughter killed her.
It was a, I knew she had a daughter and so, so
Gary starts going through this narrative of what he did to Carol the
last time. She was a,
in a hurry. She like was allegedly in a rush and she didn't like it.
Kind of like hurt his feelings. Wasn't sad
fighting me with it would make me mad cause you very much Noree
she had some melt in her mind and I
killed her killer,
a chapter with my arm and weight killer cared for because I dated before but
this tape didn't turn out right
up until that point.
Gary refused to say that from the minute I picked these women up,
I wanted to kill them. He claimed they were in the middle of a sex act.
He would get distracted, something would happen. He just kind of went crazy.
He had snapped and almost like blaming the victims and my father wasn't buying
it, whistled back up.
The fact that he kept on doing it over and over and over again was like,
come on Ben through this a lot of times before and she's already told you she's
in her. You knew what was going to happen
and you've done this. How many times have you 10 times hand,
1520 times. You know what's going to happen. She pisses your off
and you like her telling us always yes,
get you go into this knowing full well that it could end up in her desk
and Gary just says, yes, that is true. When I picked them up,
I was going to kill them. Finally acknowledging. Yeah, that's true.
There's a pause and my father just says,
why?
Why? Why did you do this?
You need to kill.
And that was a question that had haunted my father for decades.
Why isn't that why? And that one simple why that he asks Gary,
there was a lot of questions. He was asking,
why did you inflict all this suffering on them? On us?
Why did you take these women off the streets and wanting to destroy them? Why?
Why
[inaudible]
the answer is
unsatisfying.
Yes, I did need to kill killer because,
wait, what?
I just needed to kill because of that and then he just trails off.
I need to kill because of that. That's it. It just, that's, you know,
I just wanted to kill him. I just needed to kill them
in that moment. My father, he stands up and he says,
you've touched me, Gary. You touched me. Can you take a break
cable going off tape now it's two Oh nine 24 hours on June 17th year 2014 he
walked out of the room and just started weeping.
They spent the next six months interrogating him.
They brought in psychiatrists and forensic psychologists to try to get an
answer. Gary says, I needed to kill them. They go, why? And he says,
because of the rage and well, why the rage?
And because women have stepped on me all my life. Well,
why can't you deal with it in a normal way?
Each answer just begs another why.
And even though in the end they got him to confess to these 49 murders,
they never really get any closer to an answer than this first one.
[inaudible]
that afternoon he gets in his car, goes home,
he finds my mom on the deck, he sits down next to her.
She says, what happened today? My Dad said,
I don't want to talk about it.
And to this day they have not talked about that day and he hasn't talked about
it with anyone until I interviewed him for the book.
And
why is it so important do you think,
to understand the why behind such an evil act?
Well,
the thing that haunts me about the why question is that I'm reminded of like one
of the oldest stories in the Bible,
which is the story of job of the story of job is that one day God and Satan are
having a conversation and they're saying, have you checked out job? You know,
I'm really proud of Joe.
He believes in me and he trusts me in so much and he has such great faith in me,
and Satan is like, ah, I bet I can change his mind.
And so Satan basically systematically destroys job's life,
takes away his wife, his children, all his material possessions.
What follows is this ongoing conversation between job and his friends about why
does this happen? Why does God allow this to happen?
Only then does God speak up and kind of say like,
you're going to question me like, you know who are you?
My point is sometimes when we ask the why in the face of profound evil,
I kind of wonder if what we're doing is that we're daring God to show himself
and I think what we want out of the why is meaning meaning to life,
to reveal itself in a way that restores order and gives us hope that all of this
isn't just meaningless chaos.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Jensen's book is the Green River Killer, a true detective story.
It's a graphic or an illustrated novel. Thanks.
Also to reporter Aaron Scott for that story. This is Radiolab.